The way we have talked about
the rise of the social contract
following the Second
World War might
make it seem a little
bit more utopian
than was actually the case.
Wages did rise in tandem
with productivity,
and this meant a high standard
of living for many Americans.
There was also less
emphasis on shareholders
and immediate
short term returns.
There was also high
levels of job stability.
People often came into a company
without very much experience
at all and expected
to work their way up
through promotions over time.
But there we're also downsides
to employment over this period.
The trade off of job
security, of having
a stable career with a
predictable career trajectory
was often the risk of
boredom and monotonous work.
Corporations, in
the 1950s, were very
hierarchical and conformist.
Intellectual diversity and
creativity were discouraged.
These corporations,
of course, we're
also dominated by white men.
There wasn't very
much diversity,
and there were very
sizable gaps in pay
based on gender and race.
So while we can learn
a lot from this period,
it's not exactly a golden age
to which we should return.
We've made a lot of progress
since this period as well.
There's more diversity in the
workforce than ever before.
And pay gaps between
demographic groups,
though they still exist,
are becoming smaller.
With the rise of the
knowledge economy moreover--
an economy that encourages ideas
and creativity and innovation--
workers are being given
more discretion in how
they go about their work and
even the types of projects
on which they work.
Some organizations
are even trying
to make themselves look and feel
as non-corporate-y as possible
as a way to attract
and retain talent,
and there's evidence
that this can
be good for the bottom line.
In addition, due in
large part to advances
in information
technology, new technology
mediated work arrangements
are becoming more popular
and facilitating various
forms of freelance work.
Freelancing is
not new of course.
The word actually dates
back to medieval times
where one could be a
freelance mercenary for hire.
Various new websites
and applications
are springing up
throughout the economy that
connect people--
buyers and sellers--
in unique and innovative ways.
So for software,
for example, there's
companies like
freelancer.com where
someone can go on and post a
project, for example, solicit
help coding a new
website, and people
will bid on those projects.
I actually used one of these
sites not for a website per se,
but to help me learn a new
coding language called Python.
I went on the site.
I posted my project.
And I found an undergraduate
student based in California--
a very bright young man--
who stayed up with me
into the early hours of
the morning helping me
learn how to code.
And there are plenty of other
examples of technology mediated
work--
Mechanical Turk,
for example, where
buyers can pay people to do
basic, often routine tasks
like taking surveys.
Taskrabbit.com, where people
can find people to do basic life
chores for them.
And care.com, where
people can locate,
for example, house and pet
sitters for when they are away.
These alternative
modes of employment
have distinct advantages
in terms of flexibility
and individual expression.
People don't
typically have a boss
looking over their shoulder, at
least not in a physical sense.
They have flexibility
to work different hours,
often from various locations,
including their own home.
But there are common
reoccurring disadvantages
to these modes of work as well.
There are high levels of
uncertainty and insecurity.
You don't know whether
you'll have work
from one month to the next.
You don't know who
your next boss will be,
whether they'll be fair and
ethical, whether they'll
pay in a timely way.
If you have an issue
with an employer,
for example, withholding
promised pay,
it's often difficult to
resolve these issues.
There's broad, often
global competition,
which could put downward
pressure on wages.
So for example, when
I hired this coder
to help me with this
freelancing project,
he was competing against people
located in China and India.
There are other
trade offs as well.
There's isolation, a lack
of pension and retirement,
lack of paid vacation
and time off,
the need for continuous
learning that can accommodate
the diverse and changing
needs of employers,
and needing to finance
the education out
of your own pocket.
In addition, many
of these employees
lack the protections
that are traditionally
afforded to workers under more
stable employment contracts.